difficultés du métier qui est le mien
est ce qu'on peut élargir et mettre un
plan large tous les vendredis regardez
tous les vendredis j'ai affaire à des
gens qui vont fumer pendant la pause et
je reprends sans eux que dois-je faire
est ce que je dois les sanctionner est
ce que je la dois leur dire comme un
maître d'école à y reviennent regardez
les tout penaud ils vont rentrer rentrée
ils sont tout penaud et tous les
vendredis c'est pareil un jour vous le
racontez vous êtes avec votre amie la
chanteuse vitaa et sa copine soussou
vous dites que vous avez une révélation
pour la première fois de ma vie
effectivement je pris donc je suis saoul
qui est en prières et je me prosterne
régit le front pose au sol et à ce
moment là je suis convaincu que je suis
un endroit où je dois être pour pouvoir
parler à mon seigneur
c'est vraiment comme ça que j'ai vécu
ils partent comme des environnements
favela de cinq minutes c'est la
récréation il faut que vous compreniez
ce la récréation j'ai des enfants autour
de la dalle vous êtes allé fumer c'est
ça non non non non on a pensé que vous
étiez à des fumées
personne
quand il
mais moi
[Musique]
wahaha
hier enfin
encore accro à 0 je crois que c'était
réglé cette histoire mois à la mousse
corps et isabelle huppert isabelle
adjani et catherine de noël robin
emmanuelle béart nicole garcia enfin ils
voulaient faut tout la même tapé valérie
pécresse mais
[Rires]
c'est vrai quand vous voyez la première
fois à l'écran en serge benamou en grand
écran vous sentez pas à l'aise non pour
toi parce que c'est un personnage
extrême j'étais groupe comme un cochon
sortez de là ça que je vous voyez c'est
vrai ouais non non c'est la vérité si je
mens 2 oui je suis sorti je suis allé
vraiment aux toilettes ouais je suis
allé vomir je suis montré les notes puis
qu'il fallait faire en fait si je sais
bien avant il soutient des programmes
parce qu'il veut chanter
j'ai peut-être un peu tard c'est comme
si moi je prenais à faire du patin à
glace et puis elle te le dire la chanson
elle a besoin de personne alors
qu'est-ce que tu comprends à ça toi bac
il faut que je dégage
je crois que ce serait bien tu nous
laisses entre chanteurs
[Applaudissements]
moi
le groupe va enchaîner les reprises
d'acdc à led zeppelin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce matin un lapin a tué un chasseur
à la fin
voilà
[Musique]
chanson
paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
son merci à tous
bonjour bertrand chameau à je voulais
profiter de cette vidéo pour vous
remercier sincèrement pour votre don à
ma campagne alors il est vrai que comme
j'ai été une source inépuisable
d'inspiration pour vous ces derniers
mois et pour vos blagues à deux balles
comme vous dites il n'était pas anormal
que vous versiez quelques royalties et
vous avez vu je ne vous en veux pas je
vous ai pas retourner votre don mais
rassurez vous vous n'êtes pas pour
autant inviter à mon anniversaire une
image celle d'un chien pas comme les
autres il se prénomme marie faye et a
été désigné comme étant le chien le plus
laid du monde lors d'une compétition
organisée à pétales oumma en californie
une coiffure punk sa langue pendante en
permanence ce chien de race chinoise est
âgé de 17 ans il a battu aux neuf autres
concurrents ce vendredi lors de ce
concours annuel a organisé depuis
plusieurs décennies ce chien les cvo
match à ta mère
ta mère
alors vous m'aviez rêver en céline dion
et je vous ai un petit peu déçue mais je
vais vous faire une confidence
l'élection présidentielle ce n'est pas
te voice et les français vont bientôt
s'en rendre compte alors je vous
souhaite de bonnes vacances à un bon été
parce que quand vous êtes en vacances ça
m'en fais aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à ça moi s'il vous plaît on va faire des
squats de côté paraît que c'est fait
mais qui dit ah bon ben si c'est fini
n'obligeait pas chez vous vous pouvez
aussi essayer à la serre et les gens et
voilà si vous avez ou encore ferrer a
pas là
voilà
alors